m
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain éditorialistes bonsoir à vos
côtés bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes bonsoir également avec nous
denis jacquet entrepreneurs bonsoir
messieurs alors vous avez écouté avec
attention à l'intervention du chef de
l'état docteur le grand jeu commence
avec vous les mesures annoncées ce soir
est ce qu'elles ont répondu à vos
attentes
alors j'ai bien entendu qu'effectivement
on n'avait pas perdu le contrôle mais
qu'il fallait reprendre le contrôle donc
ça c'est bien on a bien compris ce que
ça voulait dire
et effectivement le couvre-feu donc un
cessez le feu qui a été négocié
j'imagine entre la diplomatie française
et le virus du corona virus pour que ça
ne se passe plus que la nuit et que donc
il n'y ait plus de contamination la
journée on est absolument stupéfait par
ça alors par contre quand même un
message qui est clair c'est ce fameux
message de pas plus que six à table ou à
6 à se retrouver
j'ai cet enfant je ne sais pas comment
je vais faire mais je pense que pour le
coup c'est un excellent message parce
que réellement on a besoin et je le dis
depuis assez longtemps que les contacts
sociaux notamment dans la sphère privée
soit le plus limité possible et donc ça
c'est peut-être la mesure la plus
évidente qu'il fallait prendre encore
faut-il qu'elle soit appliquée et je
comprends bien keita a du mal à faire
appliquer les choses dans la sphère
privée alors des mesures sanitaires des
mesures économiques également denis
jacquet en tant qu'entrepreneur vous
êtes dans quel état d'esprit ce soir
après avoir entendu le président
puisqu'on imagine qu'avec le couvre-feu
on le sait bien qu'il va y avoir des
entreprises qui vont être en grande
difficulté
côté je vais faire un peu d'humour comme
note mon prédécesseur mais on n'a pas
perdu le contrôle certes on ne l'a
jamais eu donc effectivement c'est très
difficile de perdre le contrôle un
contrôle qu'on n'a jamais eue la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il a repris la
repris plusieurs fois le mot
d'infantilisation pour dire qu'il n'en
faisait pas c'est exactement ce qui se
passe quand on est en train d'en faire
donc j'étais en train de discuter avec
un ami au téléphone en venant dans le
studio un pareil en taxi en dix ans mais
j'ai l'impression d'avoir 50 d'être de
retour en maternelle et d'avoir un
professeur qui m'explique au bout de six
mois de virus ou on n'entend parler que
de ça tous les jours à longueur de temps
qu'il faut utiliser du gel hydro
alcoolique ou des masques je me
demandais vraiment s'y soit il pensait
qu'elle et 68 millions d'attardés
mentaux ou si véritablement on était
sourd depuis le début de la crise et
qu'on n'avait pas compris le message
moi je retiens trois terme la première
chose c'est qu'on est définitivement et
officiellement en dictature mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
prononcer ce mot aujourd'hui en france
on a commencé par nous consignés chez
nous on a continué en fermant les
frontières je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui au mois d'octobre les
frontières européennes sont toujours
fermés et en gros en dehors de l'europe
vingt pays ou moins dans lesquels on a
le droit de se rendre ce qui est une
première mondiale
on n'a jamais vu ça nulle part sauf en
période de guerre
je vous rappelle juste qu'on n'est pas
en période de guerre donc on est
officiellement dictature d'autant que
dans un process démocratique vous le
savez mais normalement un maire qui
était lui a le pouvoir sur sa ville un
président de région sur sa région et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est à nouveau le
pouvoir central parisien qui impose sa
loi sans même concerter les élus locaux
et les élus régionaux la deuxième chose
c'est l'incohérence le le médecin le
rappeler tout de suite donc le virus
effectivement commence à contaminer à
leurs avants au dessus de 5000 personnes
en regroupement à puis tout à coup à
mille parce que le virus tout à coup ils
attaquent à 1001 il est vraiment méchant
ce virus tout à coup tous les deux mois
il change de cible il change de volume
il faut s'y adapter
on peut s'engouffrer dans le métro avec
des tonnes de personnes qui sont à côté
de vous mais on ne peut pas aller dans
un bar le soit enfin la cohérence est
juste stupéfiante d'un point de vue là
d'un point de vue intellectuel enfin je
veux dire même un enfant de cinq ans a
compris qu a aucune cohérence dans ces
mesures puis la troisième chose c'est
l'inconscience est là pour répondre à
votre question c'est pas keith avoir un
impact sur les entreprises
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on estime qu aura
soixante et une entre 61 et 64 mille
entreprises de moins de 20 salariés qui
vont fermer dans les deux prochains mois
et on pense que ce double vapes
ce chiffre va peut-être doubler à partir
du mois de janvier le temps que les
tribunaux assume les liquidations
judiciaires même chose mais je crois que
c'est le professeur toussaint qu'il
rappelait sur un plateau avec lequel sur
lequel j'étais avec lui il ya très peu
de temps et il rappelait que 17 millions
de passages dans les clubs de gym depuis
le mois de juillet 200 contamination est
sous le contrôle du docteur un
contaminés n'est pas un malade puisqu'il
peut être totalement asymptomatique et
pourtant on ferme les clubs de gym donc
voilà on peut aller dans le métro mais
pas faire de la gym
si on est assis le virus passe au dessus
si on est debout il passe sur le côté
mais tout à coup à 22h il attaque c'est
ridicule je pense que on est en train de
vivre la gestion de crise la plus
ridicule heures pas la plus ridicule au
monde 1 il y en a d'autres comme nous
mais je rêve aujourd'hui d'être avec mon
interlocuteur brésilien d'hier qui dit
voilà on recommence à vivre la
plaisanterie a suffi et maintenant on
reprend notre vie parce qu'aujourd'hui
avec 60 morts en france on n'a aucune
raison de mettre à sac notre économie
est malheureusement et c'est pas méchant
ce que je veux dire même si on était à
deux ou trois cents morts dans un pays
où on a habituellement entre 1600 et
1800 morts par jour ça ne change rien
enfin et j'arrête avec ça relisez les
statistiques de l'insee qui viennent de
sortir
mars avril et mai en france il y à une
augmentation diminution de la mortalité
par rapport il ya eu beaucoup plus de
morts en 2018 en mars 2018 qu'en mars
2020 et en ce qui concerne avril et mai
il ya eu plus de morts de 0 4% et
uniquement sur les plus de 84 ans donc
on est en train de mettre à sac notre
économie pour un nombre extrêmement
limité et je le dis avec toute la
réserve et toute la luminosité du monde
un nombre extrêmement limité pour
quelques centaines de patients on est en
train de condamner 68 millions
d'individus
vous avez des mots forts ce soir qui
n'engage que vous bien évidemment alexis
poulain néanmoins vous qu'est ce que
vous retenez de
de cette prise de parole des manuels ce
macron ce soir et ce qu'il a répondu aux
interrogations des françaises du tout il
a simplement mis les français dans une
position de dépendance d'infantilisation
même s'il s'en défend
ce qu'on retient de cette allocution
c'est que visiblement le travail protège
du virus parce que en dehors du travail
tout est interdite le couvre-feu mais
quelle est cette idée du couvre-feu à
part d'interdire aux gens d'avoir une
vie sociale d'interdire aux gens d'aller
et venir comme ils veulent c'est
incroyable nous vivons en france une
démocratie libérale en europe qui est
totalement guidés par le libéralisme et
là nous avons des dirigeants qui
décident de manière totalement mais mais
mais sans vote sans rien c'est à dire
qu'on est encore cadre de la démocratie
qu on est dans les lois d'exception
on est dans la danse est dans cette
guerre sanitaire qui leur permet de
pousser les lois d'exception et qui nous
interdit de nous déplacer librement
mais pourquoi nous devrions accepter ça
je suis citoyen français j'ai été outré
par ce que j'ai entendu ce soir par le
petit sourire narquois de monsieur mâcon
qui disait c'est difficile d'avoir 20
ans en 2020 mais je crois que c'est
difficile d'être citoyen français sous
cette présidence parce que depuis 2018
et pas 2017 je pense qu'il est urgent ou
tout allait à peu près mais depuis la
crise des gilet jaune
on a vu des débordements d'autoritarisme
à un point tel qu'on avait jamais connue
en france
et là ce soir on a un roi qui décide
unilatéralement de nous empêcher d'aller
et venir parce que soi-disant un virus
serait dangereux seulement à partir de
21h mais rendez vous contes de la folie
qui est en train de s'imposer sur nous
devrait devrions nous accepter une chose
pareille je pense pas je pense que
derrière ce soit le grand oublié de
l'interview c'était les chiffres combien
de personnes ce soir en réanimation
combien de personnes ce soir sont mortes
quelle quelle était leur âge
quelles étaient leurs conditions de
comorbidité qui tue ce virus quel est le
danger réel
pourquoi nous en sommes là parce que
derrière nous avons des gens qui
acceptent qu'ils vivent dans la peur des
médias qui ont joué avec la peur ce
n'est pas le cas de rt frange les jours
merci et un système qui a permis à
emmanuel macron d'étendre une toile
d'autoritarisme sur un pays pourtant
libre je suis désolé ce virus n'a aucune
raison de nous
empêcher de faire ce qu'on veut après
21h n'a aucune raison de faire fermer la
porte à je sais pas combien de milliers
de restaurateurs de patrons de boîtes de
nuit de patrons de bars ce virus n'est
pas là pour tuer l'économie
or ce que nous dit emmanuel macron c'est
qu'il faut travailler pour sauver
l'économie mais il y aura des secteurs
sacrifiés et il y aura des morts parce
que c'est une guerre et il y aura des
morts mais comment peut-on accepter une
chose pareille on a un président de la
république ce soir qui nous parle
et voilà ce qu'il nous dit simplement
qu'il va nous faire souffrir qu'il va
vous faire souffrir pour notre bien tout
simplement parce que le couvre-feu
c'est une bonne chose en ile de france
rendez vous compte en ile de france vous
avez des villages qui sont perdus au
milieu des champs les pauvres gens dans
ces villages si jamais ils sortent ils
auront droit à 135 euros d'amendé
alors peut-être que parce qu'on est en
train de discuter des projets de loi de
finances 2010 21 et qu'on n'a pas le
droit de faire de nouveaux impôts
l'amande est devenu le nouvel impôt
amendes pour non port du masque amende
parce qu'on ne respectera pas ce couvre
feu
comment voulez vous quand vous sortez du
boulot rentrez chez vous à 21h les
transports vont être bondé vous allez
faire en fait des n'y a qu'au vide parce
que les gens vont être obligés d'aller
dans les tunnels dans les transports à
la même heure parce qu'à 21h c'est tout
le monde chez soi alors j'ai une chose à
dire ce soir moi je me pose une question
pendant le premier confinement à 20h on
applaudissait les soignants les
soignants ils en prennent plein la tête
ce soir emmanuel macron leur a dit qu'il
n'était pas seul qu'il allait les aider
qu'on avait besoin d'être tous ensemble
les soignants ils sont abandonnés depuis
plus d'un an depuis que les urgentistes
ont été en grève depuis que l'hôpital a
dit que ça n'allait pas qu'il manquait
de moyens ils continuent d'être
abandonnée alors à 21h quand le couvre
feu va commencer qu'est ce qu'on va
faire un os naître est-ce qu'on va
applaudir ou bien est ce qu'on va faire
autre chose est ce qu'on va sortir
est-ce qu'on va crier c'est quoi ces
mesures est ce que je me demande
on est en train de vivre un moment
totalement absurde totalement non
justifiée médicalement non justifiée
parce que je pense que beaucoup de
médecins vont vous dire que finalement
ce virus avec quelques mesures de bon
sens on peut l'endiguer du coup on va
justement posé la question tout de suite
alexis poulin a à bertrand legrand
effectivement docteur ès que ce virus
ont pour l endiguer différemment avec
d'autres mesures sans couvre feu par
exemple
oui à une première mesure qui est toute
simple c'est d'aérer les les espaces et
pour tout vous dire dans mon cabinet il
fait aujourd'hui à peu près 14 degrés
toute la journée les ce qui me rend le
pana c'est le travail le plus pénible
c'est probablement ça et pas le volume
de patients je traite qui est absolument
démentielle aussi mais ça je peux encore
le supporter mais le froid toute la
journée de 8 heures du matin jusqu'à 20
heures le soir à 14 degrés très
franchement c'est un peu pénible
voilà ça c'est la première chose mais on
est obligé d'aérer et on peut pas mettre
des clim d'eysseric ventilé il s'est
fait ouvrir les fenêtres qu'il faut
faire et on est en hiver je suis désolé
c'est comme ça et après tester alerté
protéger repenser ce prix ce triptyque 1
c'est ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état ce
soir c'est un bon cap également d'avis
en fait les mesures qui sont prises et
qui sont restrictives en fait ne font
que signé l'échec patent de la politique
de test et on n'en parle jamais assez et
on le dira jamais assez mais lutter
contre la contagion
c'est ce qui permet de préserver
l'économie et quand les ars et le
gouvernement ont décidé de tester les
cas contacts à j 7
c'est probablement la plus grosse erreur
qu'on n'ait jamais fait puisque à j-7
vous ne vous n'auriez pas les connaît
les l'épidémie vous en rêviez uniquement
vous comptez simplement les caps positif
donc c'est inadmissible quant aux tests
antigénique je pense qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui a voulu légèrement oublier une chose
c'est que moi je vois six patients par
heure donc ça fait un patient tous les
dix minutes
donc quand j'aurai honte est antigénique
que j'aurais fait à la place de mon test
besseyre je vais faire patienter mais si
patient pendant 20 minutes dans mon
cabinet donc du coup je me retrouvais
avec douze patients dans mon jardin
plus festif que je dois traiter fin
techniquement parlant comment je fais
pour mettre 18 personnes dans mon
cabinet sincèrement c'est pas possible
donc ce sera pas possible ça va pas te
fais comme ça donc on n'y arrivera pas
ou alors on perdra de tracking donc ça
c'est complètement absconse est pareil
il ya manifestement aucun médecin
généraliste qui a expliqué au
gouvernement comment ça se passait dans
un cabinet médecine générale le plus
gros échec c'est qu'on n'a pas réussi à
mobiliser les médecins généralistes à
rennes
des tests pcr pour gagner ces 24 heures
qui ne sépare le test pcr de la
prescription
alors que si on prescrit on perd 24
heures si on réalise au cabinet on gagne
24 heures en gagnant 24 heures j'arrive
à faire le tour de mon cluster enfin en
tout cas j'y arrivais encore il ya deux
semaines et maintenant depuis deux
semaines on n'y arrive pas parce qu'ils
sont trop nombreux
mais c'est ça la réalité des choses
denis jacquet en quelques mots l'avenir
les prochaines semaines les prochains
mois ça vous inquiète forcément parce
qu'on on écoute les entreprises moi j'ai
beaucoup d'entreprises dans mon réseau
je discute beaucoup avec les avec les
entrepreneurs surtout dans les
territoires ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que moi qui vient de
province il suis né dans un petit
village presque de basse-normandie
puisqu'on n'arrive jamais à comprendre
depuis paris dans cet état très jacobin
et centralisateur c'est que dans un
petit et moyen territoire c'est vrai
pour la france c'est vrai pratiquement
pour tous les pays occidentaux un emploi
perdu dans un petit et moyen territoire
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle c'est un
emploi qu'ils ne repoussent jamais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que dans
toutes les communes en moyenne de moins
de cinquante mille habitants ce que vous
perdez un jour vous ne le retrouvais
jamais donc ça veut dire que toutes les
entreprises que vous allez perdre
aujourd'hui les entreprises de moins de
20 salariés les artisans les boulangers
les restaurateurs les boîtes qui sont
liées au tourisme les boîtes qui sont
liées à l'événementiel
ce sont des emplois qui ne se recrée
rompt jamais aujourd'hui là où je suis
né en basse-normandie et c'est l'ironie
du sort le premier employeur désormais
c'est l'hôpital c'est l'hôpital donc ce
qui signifie que la crise des gilets
jaunes va nous sembler dans quelques
mois un amuse-bouche par rapport à ce
qu'on va vivre à partir de février ou
mars quand les gens vont s'apercevoir du
nombre d'emplois perdus du taux massif
de chômage puisqu'on estime qu'on
pourrait monter à 12 et peut-être 15% du
fmi qui confirme qu'effectivement la
reprise sera encore plus lente que prévu
quand on commence à dire que maintenant
on est en train de parler de juin 2021
dans lequel le le virus poserait encore
des problèmes et que le nombre de
liquidations et sa cèdent toutes les
illusions du plan de relance
il fallait le faire le plan de relance
bien évidemment pour tenir le coup
nécessaire mais un plan de relance ne
remplace pas le chiffre d'affaires donc
ces entreprises vont simplement
disparaître donc s'il faut bien
comprendre et sa dernière
c'est que nous vivons dans un pays dans
lequel 82 % des entreprises ont moins de
250 salariés
sur ces 80 % l'essentiel ont moins de
vingt salariés et donc ce qu'on voit à
la télé au journal de 20 heures c'est
airbus qui licencient 5000 personnes
c'est bridgestone auprès duquel on se on
se jette voilà pour pour les sauver une
allure bertrand legrand centaines de
mines ou allaient donc c'est sans
milliers de boîtes qui vont licencier
trop quatre personnes vont aboutir
plusieurs centaines de milliers
peut-être deux millions d'emplois en
moins merci beaucoup à vous donner
jacquet entrepreneurs d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci à vous bertrand
legrand
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste alexis poulain
éditorialistes